[Applause]
[Music]
okay cool let's do it boys Steve I'm
inviting what so what's the most we got
tonight 302 and a half all right dude we
know we know this is a gentleman for
those of you who are still here this is
the real [ __ ] right this is when the
team really shines and you'll see you
just watch we're gonna do great
we gotta beat three guys that's what we
gotta be has did everyone recent what
are you talking about
don't worry no I didn't long Terrace
there goes good together right guys
you're in your bath you could you know
we'd remember that one night till 4:00
in the morning we killed it yeah well
I'm not staying up until 4:00 in the
morning I got general Steven charge okay
this is it this is what wfe really
shines okay let's work together I'm
counting on you we got northern Cali my
rock and southern California working in
unison and it's just nothing but good
place so who's the leader Craig and your
general Steve no yeah no no don't listen
to me man go to castle work together
team shoot if it looks busy a castle and
running around the hatch easy-peasy okay
team shoot cover each other's back
mm-hmm banana wake up and Anna we need
you bro
Stevie there I'm a week yeah what you
gonna post a picture of that portrait
that's Stevie Drew of you bro I will no
no he's talking about banana a banana a
picture Oh Pikachu Leoben an alone the
fortress fortress oh yeah I see it I see
it you did pose oh no we're getting D
dog looks miss screens black oh no leave
the ship wait a second those New Zealand
dudes again it could be Pikachu are you
kind of a moan no this is a bad sign
maybe I should just cuz Craig's here
I'm just China yeah boy oh okay outside
you likes leading make some feel
important over there they went to go
into catch how'd you come around the
back
hurry up come on you're safe now and
catch here we go you guys go outside
right here go Scooby
where's tortilla pica he's heard autumn
down there's another one inside there we
go you better cut this out Oh a dog [ __ ]
oh we gotta communicate oh no this isn't
a real wfe now people will see let's go
ahead here they are go Pikachu right
behind you on your six alright let's
come castle-like left look right all
right no good to have you get the heavy
honey don't don't no enough time I'm
getting hurt
they're pushing up on you you're dead I
know it's too late a snake who's got the
heavy they took it they have the heavy
it just said it said it
I don't want to set it cuz we gotta get
killed see there's my good Stevie get
somebody up get somebody up not me come
back come back
alright hold on guys we gotta stick
together everybody ran yeah
whatever I say ignore it and listen the
crack just listen to me this is we're
gonna go to castle I'm with you Craig
we're the other guys yep break off here
we go alright guys it's a little middle
well guys I need to teach you that guy's
almost dead in there he's in that tunnel
Stevie I died oh my god
oh this is a very sick man well we gotta
focus on the same guy if there's two
guys I know but I had a guy that was
almost dead shouldn't a guy to left can
we push this guy start a plan let's go
to Castle this planet this is terrible
I'm watching a planet planet planet boom
alright
they're gonna come down left here back
up back up oh do they attack me I know
help you guys yeah back up the other guy
get the other guy I need help
there you go he's right there
I died Oh get him don't let him don't
let him get it
just don't fight him don't find he's
behind you you see your left mind you
excited if your name you got it you got
it you got it all right that was better
no I just got a little better yeah
exactly that's all you have to do I'm
gonna kill you did good banana Thanks
well they're gonna pry it let's go all
right there I'm here castle Greg yeah
but all right let's go
middle by three Stevie back up back up
Stevie Stevie regroup
don't forget
oh no you went through the window Oh
Craig is behind you
Wow God man I'm just getting I don't
know where everybody's going you know
let's just I didn't I was staying at
castle and then they shot me from the
tunnel all right all right let's go
together we go catch catch us too easy
for them because they already start in
here get them thought I'm we're good
we're good we're good we're good watch
our down there you go get that guy hey
no one guy left
don't run Pikachu are you going why are
you chasing him just stay with use it
defuse it
no no what happened here what the hell
man just get out of there and just keep
them off the but keep them off them keep
them off give them on the bomb and we
can win it's over
we can't win no no we can win but we got
a we got a like play smarter I Pikachu
you're running off I saw you run away
from the hole gir gotta stay with them
okay so join me [ __ ] first castle
yeah I think Pikachu sometimes doesn't
stuff to aggravate me
all right there Oh back Oh
[ __ ] a [ __ ] work [ __ ]
it's a warm-up all right how do we lose
to three guys
but we didn't win one so we're good yeah
we can still go we gotta work together
huh because you guys jinxed it you said
New Zealand I will say right now Pikachu
you were not following us a lot of time
hey don't blame him hey we mean let's go
okay let's clear the car oh no we can
still go right yeah we know he does this
all the time when we play now we have
more viewers when we're getting our
asses kicked 17 now it's 26 this is
Hornets like bad for the channel you
know what I mean it's great up to the
name we got B point well you know what's
right I just leave it at that we we know
we know the real what happened last week
we know the real so let's do this so
that wasn't as bad
yeah we won't hear the good news -
getting these guys is you're all good
people and that counts for something
hey good people thank you it's your
phone the phone I'm telling you just put
in your phone you gotta put it far away
because you keep looking at it and it's
distance from you so if you could bring
it over here weird pictures on there you
might not want to see I'm not I don't
care about your dick pics
[Laughter]
why does everyone Gilbert Gilbert I did
finally we've actually done good when
were you when we play together
but we have to like support each other
what do you see the hard light what's
the other gun time war inspired these
guys like I haven't what are you talking
about no we have not okay okay there
they seem good it doesn't matter what
they look like you're right dude you're
right dude we beat that one team that
was like all right hi let's do this
castle let's play it car Wow the one of
their players message me you said back
out so you don't ruin your negative
Katie
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
dude yeah fine do you have people like
that should not be able to even play the
game that's when I wish we do have a
coke on that's a dick move dude okay
what do you say what do you say hey dude
that's like the past there's a new team
he was talking [ __ ] - [ __ ] vulgar no
these guys are talking [ __ ] too vulgar
what were they saying backed out back
outs they don't ruin your negative KT
that guys [ __ ] hurt I'm down you guys
old town all [ __ ] this - no no [ __ ] this
guy over just one right I know I know
[ __ ] these guys I'm beyond you
Baram Oh Carla
they're both right there which is remind
us you get hurt nice he's pushing that's
all right well we got three of them down
there talking all this [ __ ]
we still got almost all of them down
sorry guys I didn't mean to lose my cool
I killed electro let's go in the room
planting planting yeah it's plenty of
these cars let them get there Craig -
[ __ ] yeah
one thing we got to do is just keep calm
getting too amped up like let's just
work together a shoot oh I think my
battery's fading is it yeah I got
another battery but let's just try to
get these guys let's go
I think they'll come cast ass I don't
give a [ __ ] about us but that's fine
some team shots right here right they're
gonna shot right here yeah stay there in
future long [ __ ] they're going for
[Music]
where'd he get you with what the last
hope [ __ ] we just need to start
mashing as a team yeah we should we get
out work we got to stay together I don't
know we all keep running off cuz that
guy I was killing was one dude if we had
two people on him we gonna cut em just
stay back
push hard Craig I know that's what
that's a problem they flank they push
super hard okay yeah you got this banana
we just gotta stick together and maybe
we just gotta push stick together and
push let's just go straight in a castle
let's go to castle together there's
usually one guy pushing let's try to get
capitalize on this guy see this one guy
he's over here let's kill this one guy
okay I'm coming wait for me there's two
there's two there's two back up and
Legolas I'm dead serious are you Steve
Otero was on the outside we've all been
together that's what I'm saying get him
Steve
nice deep one more one more
I know let me switch my battery yeah
this guy said you're a blessing to this
planet Steve what was that I'm sorry
guys I mean thought those guys were so
aggressive you know I mean I just I
didn't like their talking another
message the worst I don't know what hold
up I might disconnect from you guys cuz
I'm putting new battery
I got batteries - who said told you
you know you should what's your KD yes I
wish I mean it doesn't matter dude
they're just take see people like that
are just [ __ ] you should report that
message
[ __ ] them well you gotta press them okay
yeah yeah I'm here okay so uh I got take
a quick piss is okay while it's loading
yeah we do this we just stick together
like glue that's what I'm saying
so no matter don't get like a foot away
from any of your teammates always be so
close together attached also why I gotta
be honest I don't know why you guys
aren't doing the usual which is Maite
and Uriel's my kinda good I've used time
more sparse but it's not gonna be as
good as my tie dude I promise
see he's got an auto rifle the number
let's go oh that's different inaugural
address I've never seen that it's a yeah
Uriel's that's pretty standard blue yeah
okay let's go stay together
Castle we're all gonna go through castle
you guys look out this bison I don't see
him here okay a song got him one bit
get out of there Craig uh let's start
there's three coming that way
good grenade good grenade gonna hit
though guys Abbi
just wait just wait and hold them off
ones pushing through nice careful don't
let them thank you
there we go see if you can get us up
nice good job Stevie there you go that's
it guys oh look at that
okay Stevie we be done let's go guys
what do you want to go awesome
watch out for this this guy there's a
guy that usually goes straight it Craig
push up push up and try and team shoot
don't stand right there you gotta go
like right here going around out there
below us I'm planning oh this guy got me
cover behind us he's absolutely yeah
he's right behind the rock near the
heavy he's gonna try to get the heavy
right now he's got the heavy I'm down
alright
Craig don't let him get it they're all
fair yeah I thought I got him office
three of them on it no there's no I
thought we got it once you shot one of
them that's all right I thought we got I
didn't have yeah maybe yeah I thought I
was out of grenades could get all that I
am I just find this behind us as well
coming out behind this he's dead
goddamn it was smoke
someone grab the heavy let's get these
hurt he's hurt he's coming around back
behind castle and standing there there
he is get him Pikachu doesn't get him
he's running he's running
hey good job guys good job we got this I
didn't do anything
cuz yeah we're doing good I thought you
hit him with the grenade oh I'm dead how
did you post grain gilligan absolutely
watch out watch out they're coming out
one nice there we go other dudes right
there the [ __ ] out of that corner then
Arthur get up okay the power there we go
there's another one good this last guy
in the heel good shot good job guys up
someone's teabag e3 quarters maybe
almost three quarters
oh [ __ ] get out of there [ __ ]
I will ones down don't get too cocky
right there guy up whatever you do I'm
gonna get trying to get heavy there you
go
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] we're both down in the back
there I'll try to revive you
good more there he's by her body
we're saying around the corner he's a
guy rift he's got rift
come on there Stu y'all good [ __ ] guys
yeah we got this what let's go to cutie
baguette in the hall time catch let's go
to catch let's go to catch this time
that's all much cuz they're waiting for
castle yeah up there's a guy in catch
oh that's it yep there's one right here
it's two guys there's two good job good
job
get a nice fold a good job Stevie nice
we did not win we have won oh god damn
it
yeah I'm not over til it's over okay we
almost want okay I got my Nova bomb
castle again come on come on so Stevie
run out to the left here Branca left
here I throw right at them right here
right here yeah okay do it first hard
oh I got three that's what I'm talking
about ice blasts guys in the back please
down be back Pikachu belongs one good
[ __ ] guys I'm saying you did a good job
because they weren't expecting you hey
what's it says way to go you almost did
[Laughter]
so let's just clean slate guys let's do
the same kind of format I like that
to be honest so we got lucky because
those guys were just ok I still feel
good no we did good there were decent
team now do we have enough to go to the
spire problem check yeah coming you guys
bro dude I have like 50 yeah 41 here we
go
come on low just the other side
well I know sod Stevie used to go to
church I go with my girl sometimes
Catholic Church huh I thought they don't
allow sex before marriage hey Chris I
don't gotta worry about Enoch I don't
got a girlfriend so hunter my boy Oh
better devil Phoenix always rise mmm
antidote
legends of though yeah but he's really
got Pikachu
my man where were you guys one thing you
should worry you why would you run out
that hard
she's price one in the middle of
everything nice wall girl there guy
he's got rockets he's over by Pikachu in
my body through that tunnel what the
hell oh all right
just don't let him get to it Arthur
hold them off damn he doesn't have a
token he doesn't okay
just keep him off of it just watch out
jump jump around jump around jump around
good job castle yeah well pika - fine
they're going to catch
[Music]
but all right can I get the guy
yeah we're fought I'm down we can't take
that long they're all it'd be I die our
done yeah we can't take that long if
this [ __ ] it's all right let's go castle
don't want anybody getting AIDS yeah
watch out we're all dere watch our job
all right where's that [ __ ] I'm dead
they're all right there watch out for
stringer the tunnel
there we go it's too pushing in front of
that guy's dead
train is gonna get heavy there's another
one in the tunnel around the corner nice
good let's not get too ahead of
ourselves
yeah don't teabag yeah no TVs number one
let's go I we know they're gonna go
catch so let's go catch catch okay so
teabagging is easy when you're small ah
that's right yeah catch catch
besides goes to well no we're defending
heard we're stopping them [ __ ]
I'm here I'm here behind us where is
everybody
I [ __ ] that up dude I'm doing [ __ ]
here what's up behind you behind you
nice get somebody up get a setting oh oh
yeah get somebody up right there he's
gonna get up all right that's fine
oh do you have that yeah dismantle
they've got the heavy heavy all right
the yellow ones coming from the behind
furniture for entrance
oh no he's put you know all right but I
don't understand why he didn't died
[ __ ] before [ __ ] you [ __ ] dude don't
worry about it new new rounds okay shot
that guy in the back I like I was right
behind in a fury I know I saw I'm just
saying that's [ __ ] whacked
I will try and Castle young anybody at
grenades no I don't ya gonna come on
[ __ ] man I should have gone underneath
training plans [ __ ] just wrong
I kill the top player oh yeah just
hiding all right we gotta switch it up
or get it to predict we're getting too
predictable huh I think they're gonna go
Castle this time that's what I think I
think you're wrong but okay well split
off I mean experiment see there's one
here
you have a grenade he's running back
around bak
there's two Stevie let's push together
push this guy oh there's two of them
it's two on two yeah I lit up also
is on your left to pretty get you yeah
they're gonna be a castle guys cuz we're
dead good intervention I just didn't
know where you went though when I was
shooting that guy we could bring her
back good
all right here let's go catch actually
you guys go catch I'm gonna start at a
castle I'm coming this way
this way then don't push ahead yet
without me yeah what's that we did set
up shields back protect it there you go
huh damnit this guy's slippers [ __ ] he's
got grenade so back up don't stay right
together I'll die die they're all coming
in
all right well those clothes is a good
attempt now if they were wouldn't you
sooner yeah that's my bad a hundred
percent I'm gonna be I'm gonna say
they're gonna go catch this time I'm
staying with you Pikachu's up to my
right the guys always right there
yeah Castle yeah all right
slams time time time time time time
oh my god he's dead
I need help though
let's just play the card out on yeah
let's play the card out damn it
Chloe could add those guys but it's okay
life bar alive well I know Pikachu's on
here just posting the whole time what
are you doing I said he's posted his fan
base cook who your top have a good one
you gotta you gotta do it
Stevie you got that just I know but you
got it oh sorry sorry guys we get clean
card you want to try just yeah let's
just if we don't do it this time you
know we'll just we'll just quit hey
Steve don't clear your card I just
cleared it or banana bananas clear come
on just clear come on we could do it all
right let's go they're just gonna try to
keep women on that card but it doesn't
matter either way
right what are we doing wrong I don't
know we just we need to be team shooting
like what what scope that's all we're
doing wrong one more yeah I'm ready dude
I just want to know that we keep we keep
branching off once we see someone he
said what right just keep pushing
together that's what I'm saying going
that's what I call of all on me yeah so
let's do one more and if we lose and go
yeah yeah it's good about it I'm saying
I'll stick together like the same guy
it's not that easy though cuz sometimes
I'll throw a pulse grenade to split the
group up there's a lot of very true but
you can jump around it or if you're
moving
go you know around or jump around or
straight in Harry so I know I know I
know that's the thing your fellow I know
I know I put the brakes on a little bit
Little Billy is only at a four what I'm
saying is just follow me to that point I
am but you're going ahead of us that's a
problem you're going ahead of us put the
brakes on all right all right you guys
yeah we're gonna die yeah and then
you're gonna stay right here right and
you're gonna watch this part oh yeah
all right well watch this on one part
with me and then if you see them coming
they're coming
I got one gun okay guys get the heavy
and go to catch crank you get it Craig's
got to have yeah this one in front of
you nice Craig you got one all right
Steve me Craig oh [ __ ] I don't want to
86 guy oh we got to defuse this man what
are we doing here
oh he's using the cold our Pikachu's
favorite gun yeah oh my god oh where are
we going
catch catch catch breath Oh quick and
here you go up the middle quick they're
getting into one there's invisible fall
back fall back for grenades house
flanking go right go right go right guys
all right oh come on Craig I need you
see that
yeah ran past a grenade exactly you said
keep running I was you guys know what to
do
oh you don't like being captain
help me with this guy there he goes it
seems you didn't see what you didn't got
him okay
fall back fall back they're gonna go
catch this rule with the catch come on
rotate the catch
we're all rotating oh he comes into
rocket I'm at the car we're just going
he's on our check
yeah maybe lucky gaming I'm very good
good game that's hilarious
he knows what he's playing with we have
a chance boys better than us we can see
behind us wait who am playing against I
know this there on the chat look at them
baby huh easy baby lucky
I want to work he said I will show you
at all
new year number what we really go to
spire yeah hey good game guys baby baby
lucky you guys did a good job podcast
hey check out where the house fire team
ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]